I know that there's so much that we
can't talk about did you get in trouble
when you said that the princes were in
this movie no I didn't I didn't but what
was that they like well it's it's like
put the royal family in big spooby well
I mean so hard 1 2 are you there I can't
go further into it
you can't go further into it yeah wish I
could have you met them before
Nicholas you have you met them before
I've yet they came in they did an
official visit which was in the press ok
yeah truth is he's not like new news no
they came on set yeah look if you
picture right it was cool I know your
best friends
[Music]
starwars the last Jedi picks up right
where the force awakens' left off with
certain characters expanding their
powers and others looking for justice so
this is the battle between you and
phasma that's what we see in the trailer
yep what can you tell fans about that
it's tricky does it finally go down yeah
I mean when you put your boss in a trash
compactor what do we do with her
it's a garbage chute trash compactor
yeah there is and then you leave your
job you come back to do some evil in her
eyes yeah you have about to get messed
up right that's my [ __ ] she isn't
playing and I don't want to go back to
my old job
so I'm gonna fire
if you have to carry is not here to
celebrate with you guys during all of
this what's that I think it's strange
especially watching the movie I wish to
move with first time last night so it's
strange you know having to you try and
separate the character from the reality
but the end of the day it means so much
to a lot of people and so strange
feeling but I think that I think she
does a great great job in this movie and
she has a lot of weight on her in this
and it's not an easy part to portray I
think she nailed a spark
[Music]
I'm sure it's sunk in just to the level
of fame and attention everything else
that you you have in this but when you
start thinking of star wars have you
started thinking that this may could
possibly be about the next five but like
the next 20 years of your life the last
Jedi the lost year back okay so we just
just concentrate on this in this film
for now for now yeah yeah I take it each
project at a time I think there's
something unhealthy about thinking about
20 years in the future we know if this
planet is gonna still be come on dude
it's tricky times we it's by grace that
we are live on each thing okay if the
world is still here yeah we'll see you
would be cool yeah we don't know right
we don't know but again we don't know
thanks for that